[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh here we go guys bubbles I'm in what's
up Bob lights I'm your host Josh Thole
and we're getting it to Marvel's Ironman
VR exclusively for the psvr this game
comes out on July 3rd the demo which
you're getting into right now is
available now if you don't have a psvr
it's ok the bundle with Marvel's IV
about VR also comes out on July 3rd
PlayStation 4 sold separately so you can
suit up
ok here we go the soundtrack is so good
let us know in the chat if you're able
if you've played it before and what
times you've got I I won't be able to
comment on chat because I have the VR
headset on but let us know if you're
playing the game use the hashtag suit up
please return the play area okay got a
play area alright
alright alright alright let's get into
this dev Oh Tony Stark retires from
weapons making to become the armored
superhero known as Iron Man at home in
Malibu he tests his first modern armors
flight and weapons system DoubleTap to
engage boost thrusters can be
comfortable played either sitting or
standing hold the start button to
recenter cool so we're starting in
Malibu oh man your health bars at the
bottom of the heads-up display good your
mission critical
oh the breathing the hard
oh man the beads children
all right hands out engage
those are sounds of the sounds okay mark
three Testament are starting with
maneuvering thrusters ants by my sides
mom's back
good feels good all right
time to open her up
oh look I can just float
why for
oh it's so it's that's so cool so many
interactive entertain
the marvel
camouflage
[Music]
yes all of his mouth
[Music]
opening targeting sweet the posters
ready hands up palms
fools
[Music]
Oh
you may have a problem Tony pepper I
have a lot of problems I'm serious you
and this armor do I need to stage an
intervention
where are you anyway look out the window
oh hi handsome
five hard
two more targets left
one more
[Music]
that's how it's done what's next oh yeah
mind if I watch you know I work better
with an audience start the flight test
alright alright let's see with my yacht
hey what's up
let's start with boost all right time so
here we go
I swapped the DC motors can reduce my
drag coefficient by 10 maybe a 10.5%
okay should I be writing this down no
need
never mind like a steel trap oh yeah
when's my birthday sorry
pepper cutting out it sounds like you
need to reduce your BS output no normal
range warm up the Jets I want to punch
them this Rockets engaged time to throw
it knocking just like happy Hogan Tommy
time to punch out 40 over 35 38 no huh
oh man camouflage 38 429 are you serious
let us know in chat if you're able to
beat that score or if your will be my
score which I'm sure everyone that's
probably already done I would love to do
this again
maybe later after a part of that sounds
great
meet me back here when you're ready
I'm proud of that
[Music]
ego his land 49 okay I'm happy with that
that's a good score start jet 20,000
feet
five years after downing the mask of
Iron Man Tony flies home aboard stark
Force One his private jet
Tony obsessively upgrades his armor
designs leading from the prologues mark
three-bar force one term six private jet
of the 737 refitted for comfort
strange
oh I can't pick this up Stark shanghaied
again private island destroyed Roxxon
denies involvement open the suitcase
cable Oh nope oh man I lost my tablet
though just the Mach 3 so give me give
me I want give me give me give me
morning sir hey fellow man I got you
something hey Friday you seen pepper
I believe she's putting out a fire can I
start it she's been on the phone with
the press all morning something about
your surprise announcement caused quite
a stir well don't you watch the news
Tony Stark no stranger to stunning
revelations shock the business world
today when he gains pepper potts the new
CEO of Stark in conference mr. stark
admitted he had not informed miss Potts
of his division prior to the
announcement
perhaps you jumped the gun sir it's the
opportunity of a lifetime she's gonna
thank me I gonna kill you all right well
I'm your assistant Tony you need to warn
me before you do stuff like this you're
not my assistant you're the CEO of Stark
Industries or don't you watch the news I
should I'm gonna
I'm usually tell me here's the thing I
wasn't put on earth to sit behind a desk
and you weren't put here to handle my
unpaid parking tickets I was gonna ask
if there any more of them there glove
boxes full of them that's not the point
the company turned a corner years ago
we're a force for good in this world and
I want you to get that message out there
don't people always try to shoot the
messenger Oh pepper Friday who taught
you how to fly you did sir unfortunately
I'm not in control right now reserve
someone has taken a sofa out there it's
a stock drone we don't make combat
drones anymore the drone is encasing
itself in some sort of hardlight shield
hello do I know you I'm just a ghost
from your past okay officer this
three of them a suitcase office - please
- please - please okay that's not good
whoa okay that's not good suit suit suit
suit
your airline just lost my luggage
overwrite my safety go this is example I
know just come back in one piece
oh here we go just for to put out of a
flame
oh man
ride a feeling a bit naked here my
gullet I gotta go this should come in
handy yeah I've gotta let it bounce a
pepper the grounds getting awfully close
[Music]
I'm ready mysterious assailant blows a
hole in Starks jet Tony Don's the Iron
Man armor midair to defend pepper and
the jet let's go let's go let's go we
got you I got your pepper
I love this one before the breathing and
the HUD you're actually wearing a helmet
all systems online just in time we got
playing to cast do this here we go Topsy
can you hear me
chapter one
so we have a massive breach in the home
world news Friday tell me about
something I didn't just jump out it
scanning yes Kim that plants get that
way
there's an engine fire that needs your
attention or it's not the right engine
sir God
by a suppression system online
that's one less burning issue to deal
with good job son
so the autopilot is no longer responding
and the jet is projected to crash into a
populated area that's what this applies
to the sky literally in the sky reduced
about anymore from our mystery guest
they're giving us the silent treatment
with the hounds of calling for the duel
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
Oh scanning for miss Potts
this plane is like literally facing the
ground my Hut
they've also locked me out of the Jets
Diagnostics I have no read on miss Potts
do you copy
enemies inbound
pepper come in
yeah
control the jet keep the good news
oh it turns to blue when you're not in
combat and in yellow when you're in
college
Oh
oh whoa whoa okay I can't steer so the
aileron on the left side has been
damaged
who's that fixable I'll have to wing it
that looks better great pepper you think
you can land this bird
[Music]
letting your doors are malfunctioning of
course there
yeah
it's all yours pepper tears - three
green well done
never good we're good has any further
objections I say we call get out of my
head
stop acting rude so I'm detecting a new
energy signature more enemies good
trigger fingers getting itchy that's the
new enemy type oh oh
No
Polaroid's neutralized but I'm sensing
our hacker friend has returned what I
can't
Friday can't use my thrusters Friday all
systems are down the big ones back
come on come on Friday come on get me on
getting in this toward
I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming so I
believe the jet is officially aloft
three a compartment
I'll meet you under the jet
Oh
[Music]
come on Tony take it to our covers over
my head my husband I'm connecting oh my
sweating oh my sweating right now
Oh we'd love to play will be dumb pepper
next time I want my own seat yeah that's
a really good idea
suit up July 3rd Marvel's Ironman VR yes
oh my goodness that felt incredible it's
like oh my god my heart is like beating
miles per hour it's like that feeling
you get like you know when you're a kid
and you're like you look up to these
heroes that you've you've read and
you've seen like man I want to I want to
I want to be like that what is it like
to be a hero
this is literally what it feels like to
be hiding but I got feel like I'm Iron
Man and I've never played anything like
this before in my life
oh my god the kid in me is like I'm
gonna don't and I'm still like oh man
this is a free demos I'm always free if
you have a psvr you can get it right now
I strongly recommend it if you don't
it's okay the psvr bundle with the
marvel time in VR comes out July 3rd
PlayStation 4 sold separately while
designing in VR comes out July 3rd
exclusively on the PSP our we're not
even done with this demo we still got
some other things all right let's check
out the spike courses I can either paint
some time to just I don't know how to
tony does this me I'll tell you that
right now
whoo a warning grid will appear if
you've moved too far from the center of
the play area when the warning grid
appears look down find the orange circle
Malibu flight course become one with the
thrusters become one thrusters and
complete the race as fast as you can
this is insane I can't believe this is a
free demo right now oh man just that I'm
just so immersed in this it's it's so
crazy cuz I wanna I want to be I'm in
this I'm in the world right but I have
to fight forget but I have to like shoot
debris I have to save pepper I have to
do all these things because I'm like I'm
Iron Man right now oh okay we live in a
world with this exist
back in Malibu initiating home front
flight test good luck sir
46 waypoints okay three
doing good good
nice this is nice this is nice
causes 50% complete keep it up
I see
there's the finish line
oh come on hammer with you how we do how
do we do how do we do that was so good
that was so good that was so good they
did 119 you got 133 what did you guys
get it if you played the game I played
the demo camouflage got 119 dang I
thought I did well to suit up
July 3rd let us know jack you tweeted us
as well which you got hashtag sued up
hashtag mogul at home at Marvel all
right now the fight chorus let's do the
combat challenge you really good 133 I
think that's really good let me know if
you guys have beaten me I'm sure I'm
sure you probably have combat challenge
defeat all the drones within the time
limit some object objectives and
missions have time limits the timer
displays the top of your HUD that was
nice that felt so smooth - oh I felt so
smooth Tony owns the world's only
shoreline property with a backyard oh
happy for you Tony
okay combat combat
here comes the HUD again
this never gets old this intricate ball
okay
these are auxilary weapons so hands up
whoa whoa not too shabby
I suppose you need to paint multiple
targets sir good call
reloading gunsmiths Malibu time trial
good luck
Halla boosted our lucid
[Applause]
nice okay
gonna be charged 38% sculls amount
weapons power increased
all right well visit powerful
so juber powerful I gotta keep using
that
it appears you're stealing Lancer
whether it's your increased
okay go away
oh that took us way too far
you start
we have to save it though
[Music]
not a good one I'm not doing too hot on
this one
and then there were no okay that's a
hard one I'm gonna save my unity
revenues in that
Oh God
what
bulletins in one minute
oh that's gonna hurt hard man
[Applause]
[Applause]
run out of time
no once more that was hard man yeah I
read do that again that was terrible
terrible gotta find that uniboob - yes
all right how you do this do that again
here we go first time doing it's hard
man it's hard well using the term on the
screen then yet will appear I really
obscure your peripheral vision you can
adjust the vignette effect in the
options menu combat challenge defeat all
the drones within the time okay I didn't
even get to the fifth wave
that last one was hard power weapon
power-ups temporal increase the damage
dealt by all of your weapons all right
Redemption time here we go
Tony's neighborhood neighbors are still
surprised he doesn't need a permit to
practice flying around his home for a
few regulations for personal flying
suits Benford dad do you believe in me
okay these are auxilary weapons so hands
up palms down now this impressive
accuracy reloading gunsmiths Malibu time
trial good luck sir
[Music]
boosted
all right wait one duck boom let's go
where's
ass girls heading your way sir
power boosted
loading reloading
the way out of the way nice give me wave
three let's do this let's go Friday
[Applause]
and then there were before let's go at
two minutes twenty to twenty seconds
boom oh yeah oh yeah I got my unibeam
okay
sustained significant damage
come on come on do your thing
the unity are so hard
okay how well you Naveen
I'm gonna play that again 13 seconds
where is he
I don't know how to destroy this good
time this is a hard man I need to learn
about how to destroy those things better
food $13,000 in 20 all right I got some
work to do that's for sure oh that's the
great thing about it you know you can
keep practicing yeah that's good that's
good oh man what a game guys marbles
Iron Man VR comes out July 3rd
exclusively on psvr the PlayStation VR
bundle with Ironman VR with moms on
video comes out on July 3rd as well
PlayStation 4 sold separately play the
demo now which is available right now
it's free whoo that was awesome I got a
lot of work to do as you can see use the
hash tag suit up let us know what scores
you got at Marvel Tagus on josh the way
and this is Marvel your universe
you